so I wrote an article a few weeks ago
titled we have turned childhood into a
mental disorder and I've been I've been
wanting to do a show on the topic and I
thought now's as good a time as any
especially because the main reason I
wanted to visit this topic again is
because when I mistake I made when I
wrote that articles that I I think I was
being too limited in my scope the truth
is that we've not only turned childhood
into a mental disorder we have in fact
turned the human condition into a mental
disorder we have turned humanity just
the very state of being a human being
has now turned into a mental disorder
I would I would argue
there are about 300 mental disorders
listed in the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders the DSM kind
of the Bible of mental disorders and
according to a report published on the
National Institute of Health website in
2005 about half of the population half
of the population will qualify for
mental illness at some point in their
lives their lives by the standards of
the DSM okay half of the population now
here's an interesting logical question
how can you even call it a disorder if
half of the population has it it would
be like if half of the population had
three arms let's say it would be very
hard to determine that having three arms
is a disorder or a mutation because it's
kind of like well you get one half with
that and you'll how do you know which
half is the disordered one I guess is
the question the psychiatric industry
though has has basically set out to
catalog and medicalize every human
behavior emotion inclination temptation
and personality trait
and it would seem that we're reaching a
point where nobody in America can be
considered normal and you really have to
wonder actually where do the drug
companies and the psychiatrist where do
they get their idea for what is normal
because they're talking all the time
about well that's abnormal that's
disordered okay well what is normal to
you what are you considered normal what
is it what is what is normal behavior
what does a normal person what are
normal feelings and normal thoughts what
is a normal brain because it seems like
you being the drug company's
psychiatrist doctors you very rarely
come across anything you consider normal
everyone that comes to you apparently is
abnormal so where are the normal people
is the question and you know as we look
at this mysterious rise in mental
illnesses across America you know we're
always taught about the mental health
epidemic there's and we look at the fact
that mental illness is used to be
incredibly rare and now it is it is
utterly commonplace and we look at the
fact that drug companies have so far
gotten almost 20% of the population of
America on to psychiatric drugs and when
you look at all those factors
I think you really have to start to
wonder about the chicken or the egg
because we could say that well yeah all
these people's mysteriously are coming
up with mental disorders and so that's
why they're all along these drugs but
many of these drugs cause suicidal
thoughts anxiety and depression
meanwhile a lot of Americans are having
suicidal thoughts anxiety and depression
so
could there be a link there I mean is
that worth at least considering
here's the reality before you had
millions of America Americans being put
on these psychiatric drugs you did not
have an epidemic of suicide depression
anxiety now you do and it just so
happens that these drugs they're putting
everybody on cause those things again
it's you know it's enough to make you
pause and just think for a minute isn't
it
yet we don't pause we don't even think
about this it seems like most people
would just go along with it now I focus
very often on children when it comes to
this issue
because I think nowhere is the tendency
to medicalize the human condition more
apparent or more dangerous than with
children
I mean we're putting kids on these drugs
and they're staying on them for their
entire lives
as most people know there's been an
astronomical rise in ADHD diagnoses over
the last several years and now somewhere
around ten percent of all children in
the country have been labeled with this
alleged disorder and the label is being
stuck on kids
at earlier and earlier ages and we're
now told that kids as young as three
years old three years old can be
diagnosed with ADHD there are new
medical guidelines recommend that
psychiatric drugs for kids can start at
four years old if they're quote symptoms
are quote debilitating
and a third of all kids with ADHD are
diagnosed before the age of six
and again when they put you on these
drugs there's very good chance you're
going to be on them forever you never
get mouth
it also just so happens that there's a
very high likelihood that somebody who
is diagnosed officially with ADHD as a
child will develop later on other mental
disorders and it just so happens that
these drugs they're putting the kids on
can cause those other problems down the
line again is there possibly a
connection
when you have someone who's easily
distracted at the age of four and you
put them on drugs and then at the age of
16 or 18 now they have debilitating
depression is it possible that the drugs
you've been in you've been you've been
the chemicals that you've been sending
into their brain the drugs that you've
had them on for the last ten years could
have something to do with that is it
possible of course doctors will assure
parents that the drugs are safe and will
cause no long-term damage to their
children but at best at best we don't
know whether or not that's actually true
so that it when doctors are saying that
they're lying
but they cannot just they will declare
it but they can't do it honestly oh yeah
that won't cause any problems down the
line what
there's plenty of reason to believe that
these drugs are altering your child's
brain in ways that they will feel for
years to come possibly their entire
lives and on what basis now I don't want
to focus this whole time on ADHD and
I've done you know I've written and done
shows on ADHD before but but
I think we can't overlook ADHD because
that's a big part of this whole problem
and I think it's a I think it's a
catalyst for a lot of the other problems
down the line so we should ask on what
basis do we take this incredible step as
a society to drug into oblivion what
used to be considered completely common
and normal and even charming childhood
characteristics
after all any experienced parent will
can look at a list of ADHD symptoms and
and see that they are the most normal
characteristics in the world so here are
a few symptoms of ADHD in constant
motion squirms and fidgets makes
careless mistakes often loses things
does not seem to listen easily
distracted does not finish tasks now
honestly I would be more concerned about
a child who doesn't display those
symptoms that I would be about a child
who does
so so how on earth can we take these
normal childhood behaviors and decide
that in certain cases they could be a
manifestation of a mental illness
um
[Music]
how do we do that
well the the National Institute of
Mental Health
offers a clue about this and this is
what the National Institute of Mental
Health
people who have ADHD have combinations
of these symptoms now listen to the
symptoms overlooked or miss details make
careless mistakes in school work at work
or during other activities fail to not
fail to UM to follow through on
instructions fail to finish school work
chores or duties in the workplace avoid
or dislike tasks that require sustained
mental effort such as schoolwork or
homework lose things necessary for tasks
or activities such as school supplies
pencils books tools while it's keys
paperwork eye glasses and cell phones
the Mayo Clinic puts it this way in
general a child shouldn't receive a
diagnosis of attention deficit disorder
unless the core symptoms of ADHD start
early in life before age 12 and create
significant problems at home and at
school on an ongoing basis
you notice the word that kept popping up
there school school school according to
the medical community a child's
personality becomes diseased at the
precise moment that his personality
interferes with his schooling
now that's very odd isn't
because physical diseases are judged
that way as I've said in the past if you
go to the doctor because you think you
have diabetes he's gonna run any number
of tests on you but I guarantee you this
here's what he won't ask he won't ask
you well is the diabetes causing
problems at home or at school no he's
not going to ask that because it doesn't
matter if it's a if it is if you have an
objective case of diabetes it makes no
difference whether or not it's causing
problems for you in this or that
environment it's the disease exists one
either way diabetes is diabetes at
school diabetes is diabetes at home
diabetes is diabetes when you're alone
in the for it doesn't matter what you
could be you could be on a desert island
all by yourself and you would still have
diabetes but ADHD is entirely different
because if you're on a desert island by
yourself you don't have ADHD because
it's not getting in the way of anything
if you're alone in the forest you don't
have ADHD because it's not getting in
the way of anything but the moment that
it becomes a nuisance the moment that it
gets in the way of something that you're
doing especially school now it becomes a
disorder so the disorder is subjective
environmental contextual but how can
be a disorder of the person is it not
possible that our perception is just
wrong is it not possible further
possibly that the environment itself is
disordered it's if a school cannot
function without putting hundreds of its
students on psychiatric medication then
should we not consider the possibility
that the school environment is the
disordered thing and not the kids
should we not consider that there maybe
there is something about the way that we
approach modern schooling that makes it
so difficult or impossible for eight
four eight four four children with
certain personalities to succeed and if
that's the case then should we be
changing the kids or should we be
changing the school now this diagnostic
criteria is rather peculiar especially
because advocates for ADHD drugs will
claim that the disorder can be located
in the brain and we hear this about many
mental illnesses where we're told that
oh it would you know you you do your
research you don't know anything about
the science it's in the brain it's a
this is a it is in the brain you could
see it in the brain well then answer me
this
if ADHD can be located in the brain why
is it diagnosed with a personality
survey they say they say the
same thing for depression every other
mental illness yet why don't they
diagnose these mental illnesses with
brain scans why is that if you're
telling me that oh it's clearly in the
brain well then why don't we looking at
the brain before we tell somebody that
they have this disorder and here's what
you never hear of happy here's what you
here's what never happens at least I've
never heard of this and if you have them
correct me but I have never heard of
anyone being diagnosed with ADHD or
depression or what have you and then the
diagnosis being changed or overturned
when somebody looks at a brain scan I've
never heard of that like you hear about
that with with other diseases you hear
about somebody going to the doctor
because they appear to have the symptoms
of some physical disease and then the
doctor says yeah you might have it they
run some tests and then they say oh no
you don't have so that happens all the
time with other diseases it never
happens with these mental illnesses it's
interesting isn't it because if these
things can be found in the brain then
there should be people who think they
have it but then find out they don't
because it's not in the brain
but that never happens so here's the way
that we approach mental illnesses we say
if there are neurological differences in
your brain then it proves that you have
whatever mental illness but if there
aren't any neurological differences you
still have the mental illness you see
the drug companies win either way it's a
rigged game no matter what if you have
the brain differences than you see it
proves it if you don't have it yeah well
you still have it how is that that's how
does look I admit to you I'm not a
scientist all right but you tell how is
that consistent with the scientific
process how is that medicine what is
scientific about that it's like if a
doctor called you up and said well the
AIDS test came back negative
oh thank god but you still have it what
what do you mean Esther you just said
the tests are negative now it may be
true and I admit it may be true that you
can find certain neurological
similarities among certain people who
have been diagnosed with ADHD or
depression or any number of other mental
illnesses
and so so maybe you could look at a you
could line up a bunch of quote ADHD
brains and see certain thing going on
that are similar among among many of the
brains alright
okay fine even if you could find that
you can also find neurological
similarities among people with similar
personalities and dispositions like
enthusiasm and altruism if you were to
take a bunch of people who are very
inclined to be enthusiastic like my wife
for instance
she's a very enthusiastic person and if
you were to look at her brain and look
at the brains of a bunch of other
enthusiastic people you'd probably find
things going on that are similar
you'd find the same thing among
optimists and among pessimists
you know they say that there's a there's
a for lack of a better term there is an
optimistic brain and a pessimistic brain
but that doesn't prove that these
similarities cause optimism or pessimism
or enthusiasm or hyperactivity you could
also look at the brain scan of a man who
is grieving his dead wife and you could
find his grief reflected in his brain
you could also see his happiness if his
child was just more if it you know a
moment after his child is born if you
were to do a brain skin you could see
that reflected in his brain you could
even see the kind of calm joy that he
finds in prayer reflected in his brain
but that doesn't prove that the chemical
reactions in his brain are causing the
grief the joy the closeness with God
that he feels you see just because you
find it
just because you find potentially a some
kind of correlation that doesn't prove
that the one causes the other and of
course I'm being very generous by even
accepting this idea of brain differences
after all people are still told to this
day that depression is caused by a
chemical imbalance
and drug companies still sell drugs
based on that idea you know drug company
is a seller I'm making hundreds of
millions of dollars selling drugs that
are supposed to treat a chemical
imbalance Minh but here's the thing
the drug companies know and the doctors
know that this imbalance meant does not
exist it has never been proven it has
never been found it has never been
demonstrated it was a theory concocted
by psychiatrists decades ago and they've
been trying for decades to prove it they
never have
which explains why study after study
have shown that antidepressants don't
perform significantly better than
placebos and they especially don't
perform better than active placebos an
active placebo that they would give you
an emetic 'el trial is like a isn't is a
is a a pill that doesn't do anything to
treat whatever problem but it does come
with a certain side-effect so like maybe
it's a placebo that will cause dry mouth
or something like that or give you a
headache and the reason why they give an
active placebo is because then you know
you can kind of trick your mind once you
once you've noticed you're having side
effect well then you're gonna think that
oh this is a real drug and then the
placebo effect can catch on so in other
words sometimes when they when they when
they test a drug and then they and then
and then they have the placebo those
trials are not always reliable
because it could be that the real drug
is is is actually doing nothing but it
is causing some kind of physical side
effect which tricks a person into
thinking that the drug is doing
something so
I think that could be why
antidepressants historically perform not
very well against placebos let me quote
now a paper in the public library of
science to our knowledge there is not a
single peer-reviewed article that can be
accurately cited to directly support
claims of serotonin deficiency in any
mental disorder while there are many
articles that present counter evidence
yet again
they are putting millions of people on
these drugs to treat a a chemical
imbalance Minh that doesn't exist and
that they know doesn't exist
now
and we just go along with it like I mean
it's incredible that that we all just
sit back and go along with this and
doctors go along with it
putting people on these drugs that are
gonna do all kinds of things to their
brain but are not going to treat the
actual chemical imbalance Minh ter
now here I think is the problem with our
whole approach to mental illnesses
and and and this by the way I'm not
talking about brain diseases a brain
disease like dementia where you can see
the the brain literally atrophy
now that's very different from a mental
illness and if a mental illness were a
brain disease then we wouldn't call it a
mental illness
in other words if we could definitively
see that this mental illness is caused
by something going haywire in the brain
and we could see that there's a there's
a real disease in the brain cut then we
would just call it a brain disease we
wouldn't call it a mental home but we
call the mental illnesses because they
are we say diseases of the mind rather
than diseases of the brain
you
but what is the mind and how can you
diagnose it and how do you distinguish
it from the brain
see the thing is in diagnosing the mind
has distinct from the brain a
psychiatrist is now basically looking at
the whole human person okay looking at
how somebody feels how they live how
they think and from that deciding based
on entirely subjective criteria that a
person ought not be like that
now it's easy usually this is an easy
process for it for a doctor
a doctor can look at a liver or a kidney
or even a brain and say no that's not
supposed to do that
and that's usually the mid the medical
process here is like there's a certain
organ or a certain certain part of the
body that is malfunction and so you can
look at that and you can see what the
brain does during dementia well it's not
supposed to do that clearly and so
there's a disease but with mental
illnesses we look at somebody prone to
distraction or somebody who's in despair
or somebody who has anxiety and and
doctors say well nope humans aren't
supposed to have those mental
experiences nope
or if they do have them they should have
them only for X amount of time and two Y
degree
yeah we never step back and ask
says who how can you possibly determine
that how are you in authority on how
people should think and act and feel who
put you in that position how is that
even a medical determination
a child isn't supposed to be easily
distracted who says okay based on how
what do you mean what how did you
determine that that a child isn't
supposed to be that way
you know it's very okay you could look
at a child and say he is easily
distracted fine I know that you can do
that but when you get to the he
shouldn't be part of it
what does that mean
what do you mean supposed to be
shouldn't be
in order to look at a person's like well
they aren't supposed to feel like that
or they aren't supposed to be like that
in order to make a claim like that and
that is an incredible claim to make but
in order to make that claim you must
have some idea of like the ideal person
so if I'm looking at something and
saying well it's not supposed to do that
I must have an idea about what it's
supposed to do so I can look at a
computer and if I knew about computers
that I don't but if I were an expert on
computers and the computer was having a
problem I could say no that computers
not supposed to do that and the reason
why I can say that is because I know
what a computer is supposed to do and I
can prove it for I can take a normal
computer and show you oh no this is what
a computer is supposed to do
here's what your computer is doing
here's the the you know there's a
disconnect here and so here's how we can
fix it but when you look at a person and
you say they aren't supposed to be and
feel like that well then what you have
to be able to do is you have to be able
to take a quote normal person and say oh
no that you see that person there that's
how you're supposed to be
how could you possibly determine that
and where is this normal person where is
this normal standard for a person by
which we are all being judged
um now of course if you take an entirely
materialistic view of humanity
which most psychiatrists do
then you have to believe that everything
a person feels everything he thinks all
of his traits his characteristics his
flaws his sins his desires his goals his
love his joy his despair and so on are
all just material phenomenon
but if on the other hand you factor in
the soul and free will and the
uniqueness of each person created by a
divine force then it's clear that
there's something deeper okay there is
something called a soul and that is what
drives and animates a person
he said I think it's really kind of a
philosophical question at the root of
this holder well there are many
philosophical questions we have we have
allowed the medical community and the
drug companies they have in my opinion
they have gone way beyond medical and
science they've gone way beyond medicine
in science and they have wandered into
philosophy and we are allowing them to
tackle these really deep philosophical
questions like when you say a person
isn't supposed to be and feel like that
that is a philosophical judgment not a
scientific one
another question to than a philosophical
question what drives what animates a
person
if you say that that we are nothing but
flesh and bone
then I guess you would have to answer
that what really drives and animates us
is our is our brain chemistry but if
you're not a materialist then you would
say that what drives and animates us the
animating force within us is actually
our soul or our mind
and again it comes you know so for me as
since I'm not a materialist I would say
that the soul and the mind are the same
thing now if you are a materialist I
don't even know what you mean when you
say mind what are you talking about
there's only the brain there is no mind
per se
so I'm not even sure what that means
when you get into you say the word
mental mental illness but all you
believe in is but but but you only
accept the existence of a brain
confusion you can't even define what a
mind is yet you're diagnosing it
I would say and I think anyone who's not
a materialist would have to say that
your mind is your soul you know there's
one in the same
so the point is even if a chemical
imbalance Minh
and it hasn't been but even if it were
there would still be a question about
whether that imbalance Minh is a
reflection or a symptom of the spiritual
problem problem problem rather than
itself being the cause of the problem
and even if you don't factor in the
human soul I mean this is just that's
just one of the issues here even if you
don't factor that in and even if you did
prove this imbalance materi still you
wouldn't be able to prove that the
imbalance Minh whatever disorder because
you couldn't prove that the imbalance
Minh isn't itself caused by say
environmental factors or life experience
or any number of other things
so again there are these enormous leaps
of logic that are being made when we
talk about mental illnesses and we're
just allowing the drug companies and
doctors to make those leaps and we're
not even questioning them but even if we
were to put all this to the side
even if you were to accept just for a
moment that brain chemistry determines
everything about a person
um
and even if we were to accept that there
is this chemical imbalance Minh and the
chemical imbalance Minh itself does
cause say ADHD your depression would
that still wouldn't prove that a
particular personality like the ADHD
personality for instance is disordered
it doesn't prove in other words that a
person shouldn't be that way
we've decided that kids aren't supposed
to be that way
we've decreed it from on high like gods
and then we've set out to chemically
eliminate every human disposition that
we find inconvenient or difficult but
that is subjective it's arbitrary it's
not scientific and again we do the same
thing with adults we do with all people
we look at unfavorable characteristics
emotions and personalities and we decide
that because they are unfavorable they
must therefore be medical
think that's how medicine works
so we may say for instance that somebody
has an exotic disorder
okay but who's to say that they
shouldn't have anxiety
the anxiety is disordered okay what do
you mean what is the proper order for
anxiety
say it's a disorder of anxiety okay well
what what how is anxiety supposed to
work or are you saying that there
shouldn't be any anxiety at all how do
you determine that and who determined it
and on what authority based on what
science now I have a lot of anxiety I
it's unpleasant I don't like it and no I
don't think that a person should live
consumed by anxiety but neither do I
think that anxiety is necessarily a
medical condition
and I also think that it hasn't been
proven to be a medical condition
it has rather been decided
philosophically then it must be a
medical condition
and that's a problem
you know I think it's it's possible
just possible but I think there are you
know
there are many problems that a person
can have serious problems
um difficult painful problems that
doesn't mean that the problems are
medical
it doesn't mean that they're physical at
all
there could be other things going wrong
things in your life things in your soul
that you know you just you there's any
number of other things that could be
happening to cause problems for a person
what we've done is we have eliminated
all of those possibilities and now
everything has to just be medical and
physical I'm not saying that mental
illnesses don't exist I'm saying that
there are many questions we aren't
asking and we should be
um I'm also saying that when analyzing a
person's emotional and mental issues we
can't completely disregard things like
free will choice environment experience
and the soul yet that is exactly what
we've done with mental illness and we've
done so on the word of drug companies
and psychiatrists who themselves are
still pushing debunked theories to
explain the problems that they're
supposed to be treating
that's what I'm saying and that's all
I'm saying
and maybe these are questions we should
think about and try to answer before we
continue along this path of turning
everything and everyone into a mental
disorder just a thought
thanks for watching everybody thanks
listening Godspeed